bueno
[Música]
a
escala en parís
braulio more
bienvenidos a escala en parís o en
emisión de radio france internacional en
colaboración con la televisión france24
en español la transición energética la
búsqueda de energías renovables han
generado no pocas expectativas de
transformación del consumo de energía de
manera que el planeta y los habitantes
que vivimos en él nos veamos
beneficiados y se mejore la situación de
estos no obstante esas expectativas a
veces se convierten en una enorme
pesadilla por razón de la manera como es
tratada la tierra y sus territorios en
guajaca méxico en el istmo de
tehuantepec habitantes de la comunidad
zapoteca unión hidalgo luchan desde hace
años contra una empresa transnacional
francesa électricité de france
electricidad de francia a la que le
acusan de haber acaparado territorios y
de contaminar su situado su territorio a
este propósito y para hablar del tema
saludamos a andrea manso coordinadora
del territorio de la comunidad indígena
bin isa zapoteca unión hidalgo en el
istmo de tehuantepec mexico bienvenida a
andrea gracias buen día gracias por el
espacio mi nombre es andrea manso y soy
parte de la asamblea de comunidad y
comuneras de unión hidalgo una comunidad
bin isa en el sur del istmo de
tehuantepec así usted parte de una
delegación que recorre francia desde
hace algunas semanas con el objeto de
dar a conocer precisamente esta
situación que les confronta con
électricité de france de que se trata
precisamente esta demanda contra
électricité de france de que la acusan
ustedes desde el 19 de agosto comenzamos
este recorrido por varios espacios
solidarios aquí en francia
denunciando sobre todo ante los
ciudadanos franceses lo que está
haciendo edf en nuestro territorio que
es básicamente el acaparamiento y la
privatización de nuestras tierras con
profunda violencia hacia los y las
defensoras del territorio electricidad
de france en méxico utiliza una frase
que dice encontrando soluciones para
tener comunidades prósperas y un
ambiente sano parece que no es el caso
donde ustedes no me parece una burla más
bien desde que bueno un poco para
contextualizar
edf pretende posicionarse en nuestro
territorio
implementando su cuarto parque eólico el
que sería su cuarto parque eólico en la
región del istmo en este caso en unión
hidalgo en 4.400 hectáreas de territorio
comunal desde el 2016 hemos denunciado
que la celebración de los contratos que
ha hecho edf son ilegales y que además
está pues ejerciendo una profunda
violencia entre las personas de la
comunidad que estamos en contra en la
instalación de este proyecto estamos
hablando de cuántas hectáreas muy dice
usted que ya hay tres parques eólicos
este sería el cuarto porque es ahora que
ustedes reaccionan porque no antes buena
pregunta
bueno esto tiene un un vicio de origen
nosotros fuimos parte de la comunidad
agraria de juchitán de zaragoza con 68
mil 112 hectáreas
bueno en los años setentas hubieron
desapariciones forzadas y una guerra
sucia del estado que desmanteló la
propiedad comunal de la tierra la
silencio un poco y perdimos nuestras
asambleas comunales en estos años con la
llegada de todos los parques eólicos
quiero señalar que ya hay 29 parques
eólicos en el mismo
edf sería el 30 en realidad son 28 más 1
de cf entonces
entonces en nuestra comunidad pues
volvimos a reconstituir nuestra asamblea
comunal y desde allí hemos señalado lo
que edf está realizando en el marco de
estos 28 parques eólicos que ya se
encuentran instalados en todo el
territorio ministro hay que decir que
por la situación geográfica del istmo de
tehuantepec en méxico es una región
donde hay bastante viento efectivamente
que es una manera en la que se puede
recuperar energía llamada renovables
entiendo que haya más de 1800
antenas que están conectadas con
empresas eólicas perdón de antenas
eólicas y eso hace de esta región una de
las más importantes de toda américa
latina así es actualmente hay
aproximadamente
2.300 turbinas eólicas instaladas ya y
eso lo hace el corredor eólico más
grande de latinoamérica
usted me dice 2 mil 300 instalados ya
hay otras empresas además de
electricidad de francia porque es el
pleito electricidad y francia también
hay pacto con las otras empresas han
habido en distintos momentos
resistencias de otros pueblos este
hermanos de la región en este momento
nosotros la asamblea de comuneros y
comuneras de unión hidalgo está en
contra de edf porque es la paraestatal
que pretende instalarse en nuestro en
nuestro territorio
tenemos ya instalado un parque eólico en
nuestra comunidad y ahora que estamos re
constituyendo nuestra asamblea comunal
pues decimos que ya no queremos más
parques eólicos pero qué es lo que
rechazan sabiendo que pueden ser una
energía alternativa que es lo que le
reclaman o qué es lo que le piden a
électricité de france a esta
trasnacional francesa sí bueno
denunciamos
varias son varios sentidos no la primera
es la manera en la que están
privatizando el territorio porque están
sobre territorio comunal y no quieren
reconocer que es un territorio colectivo
una forma de propiedad colectiva no y
están firmando pequeños con mails
contratos con quienes se reconocen a sí
y legalmente como pequeños propietarios
la segunda es la profunda violencia que
están pues que hay en nuestro pueblo a
partir de la entrada de estos parques
eólicos y la tercera es que la energía
que se produce no es para los pueblos de
hecho en méxico en el istmo de
tehuantepec el 75 por ciento de la
energía que se produce por los parques
eólicos va para suministrar a empresas
cementeras empresas mineras y empresas
pues que favorecen al agro industrial o
sea están en la energía de esa zona y la
venden en otras empresas así es
comunidades no tienen mayor vender y no
de hecho en nuestra comunidad y en la
región del istmo en general no hay
ninguna casa que piense en la cual un
foco se encienda con la energía
producida por los parques eólicos andrew
han tenido ustedes contacto con
électricité de france eventualmente
habido negociaciones si es el caso que
les han respondido y si no es el caso
porque no ha habido contacto con
electricidad
hemos tenido contacto con la empresa
porque cuando hemos señalado sobre todo
en
la propiedad social de la tierra la
niegan digamos que se escudan en todo
este vicio originario que ha propiciado
el estado mexicano para no reconocer
nuestros territorios comunales les
decíamos usted hace parte de una
delegación que está que en francia han
sido invitados por un colectivo francés
que se llama stop edf que cuál es el
trabajo que ellos hacen ellos dicen
acusan a esta empresa francesa de citó
una suerte de colonialismo verde es
porque no es un poco este este término
así es
llamamos bueno hemos llamado
colonialismo verde o colonialismo
energético por la forma en la que se
están implementando los parques eólicos
en nuestros territorios en este caso
esto pdf pues es un colectivo de
compañeros y compañeras solidarias que
han visitado distintos momentos las
luchas en el ismo y en este momento pues
las luchas en unión hidalgo contra la
filial contra la empresa francesa no
hablamos de colonialismo energético
porque las lógicas en las que se está
produciendo la energía sigue siendo
desde la opresión de los pueblos desde
el desmantelamiento de las propiedades
colectivas desde el de abbas también
todo de la naturaleza
ustedes diciendo un principio ya llevan
varias semanas aquí en francia mientras
tanto en méxico el pasado 20 de
septiembre si mis datos no fallan un
tribunal colegiado emitió una suspensión
contra los parques eólicos en unión
hidalgo y en la ventosa en tanto dicen
ellos que continúe el proceso legal sin
duda esto es una victoria para ustedes
me imagino pues en este amparo fue
interpuesto por por otros compañeros de
la comunidad agraria de juchitán de
zaragoza que en la que formamos parte
como núcleo como anexo agrario y para
nosotros sí
representa una victoria sin embargo
estamos esperando justamente y exigimos
que el estado y la empresa
respeten no lo que la resolución de este
amparo que a quienes han podido ver con
quienes se han podido encontrar aquí en
francia durante este gira que ustedes
están haciendo nos hemos encontrado con
diferentes colectivos en espacios
solidarios aquí en francia además de
hemos tenido reuniones con distintos
sindicatos entre ellos la cgt no para
exponerles pues el caso de unión hidalgo
y todo lo que está haciendo edf en
nuestro territorio
también hemos puesto sostenido charlas
con distintos parlamentarios en a
inicios de la gira en bruselas muy bien
andrea hace algunos meses atrás el
gobierno mexicano llevó a cabo una
consulta según esto de acuerdo a los
lineamientos de la convención 169 de la
organización internacional del trabajo
referida a los de los derechos de los
pueblos indígenas pero es una consulta
que ustedes dicen no ha sido adecuada no
ha sido lo que se esperaba que es lo que
critican de esta consulta que se hizo
el marco de la consulta se supone en la
lógica de la organización internacional
del trabajo y del convenio 169 es que
debe ser libre previa e informada y no
ha no ha tenido ninguna de estas
características de hecho lo he
mencionado bastantes veces porque es lo
que más nos pesa en la comunidad que hay
muchísimas ha detonado mucha violencia
conflictos de intereses entre casi que
es entre las propias empresas no entre
el propio gobierno más que federal el
gobierno del estado y nosotros
denunciamos la consulta porque la
llamamos una consulta simulada porque
representa un aparato para que las
empresas puedan instalarse no para pedir
nuestro consentimiento una pregunta que
es obligada el presidente andrés manuel
lópez obrador ha dicho desde un
principio desde el inicio de su
presidencia en el 2018 que con su
programa llamada de la cuarta
transformación ahora sí los derechos de
los pueblos indígenas han sido
respetados es el caso de ustedes y sino
que lo que le pedían al gobierno del
presidente lópez obrador es complejo
nosotros lo que pedimos realmente es que
se nos respete y se nos escuche no sobre
todo que se respeten nuestras decisiones
y nuestra autonomía y libre
determinación para poder reconstruir
integralmente pues nuestros territorios
y las decisiones que tomamos sobre el ha
habido contactos con el gobierno
mexicano hace dos años la asamblea de
comuneros y comuneras de unión hidalgo
envió una carta para pues escrita al
presidente andrés manuel lópez obrador
sin embargo no hubo respuesta correcta
una última pregunta si usted me lo
permite van a regresar pronto entiendo a
la mexico cuáles son los pasos que van a
seguir ahora visto este contexto que es
bastante complicado pero donde
finalmente como usted dice hay amparos
parece que la situación
se inclina un poco a su favor de hecho
este cuarto parque eloy eólico av
todavía no está en construcción así es
vamos a seguir promoviendo los amparos a
darle seguimiento a las resoluciones que
se den de ellos denunciando a edf ya
todas las empresas que se quieren situar
alrededor no sólo del territorio de
unión hidalgo sino de todo el núcleo
agrario de juchitán de zaragoza y sobre
todo pues denunciando viendo pues la
información adecuada y justa en nuestras
comunidades que es también lo más
importante pues de estas palabras
estamos poniendo ya punto final a esta
escala en parís no me queda sino
agradecerle a andrea manso defensoras
del territorio de la comunidad indígena
zapoteca unión hidalgo general istmo de
tehuantepec méxico su presencia en esta
escala muy amable por estar con nosotros
muchas gracias a ustedes les damos una
próxima cita otra semana aquí en escala
en parís gracias por su atención
[Música]
[Aplausos]